[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well there are
quite a few jets fans and uh big name
jets fans uh hank azaria
is uh one of our favorites he of course
gave us brockmire
the actor comedian does a lot of voices
on the simpsons
and he is a jets fan and uh hank joins
us now
hank how do you feel today well mackay
i mean you're right and mixed emotions
and the emotions that are mixed are
despair and anger
[Laughter]
how did you feel watching that game
it's been insane watching the jets the
last this season
because definitely rooting for them
to lose but it really goes beyond that
i mean mckay is dead wrong
it's been this weird thing i swear where
i am so
passionately rooting against the jets
that my favorite team
that week is whoever's playing against
the jets which is a tremendous win-win
because until this week
i i now always win as opposed to being a
jet fan up until now i almost always
lose
but when i mean look this this was
inevitable i guess i mean they really
they should have won that raider game
they almost beat the patriots they
almost beat the broncos they're lucky
i guess they're lucky that they're they
only lost uh they only won the one game
i should say
um but it's been a really almost
psychotic season for me but almost feels
like
this was your patrick ewing if you're
the knicks like you
you're you have a chance we're bad we
won the lottery we get patrick ewing
you know it didn't pay off in a
championship but you became relevant
like the jets aren't relevant haven't
been relevant in quite some time here
and it's jetsean to try to you know
you're bad but you're not
bad enough to get trevor lawrence here
exactly i mean look this is you know but
this is like
this is just it for a jet fan a jet mets
jets met's knicks fan by the way
i mean this is like saying are you
surprised
that lucy didn't let charlie brown kick
the football
you know you're bummed but no can you
let's see a little quiz dan
okay let's go with that metaphor charlie
brown and
and lucy in the football in this
scenario with the jets win yesterday
who's charlie brown
who's lucy and who's the football see if
you can guess
uh i don't like word problems hank
uh the jets fans of the football no
no no no jets fans are charlie brown oh
okay who's lucy uh
tom brady in the patriots
no lucy is the jets themselves it's the
jets organization
and the football i'll accept either
answer i i'd either accept
uh just the football since we're talking
about football football
football or the football could represent
uh joy in life
actual happiness okay so so recap now
lucy charlie brown in the football
represents
uh all jets fans including myself are
charlie brown poor sad charlie brown who
can't ever get it right
and lucy uh evil lucy are the jets the
jets organization who just snatched joy
away from us always
and the football is either the football
or actual joy in living
now i think i've seen a picture of you
with sam darnold are you a sam
darnold guy but you were willing like
you
you were do you have a relationship that
you can see other quarterbacks
that's actually jim brockmeyer if you
notice with sam donald
oh bronsmeier that's brockmayer right
there
that's not me that's rockman and i was
backstage i believe i was doing
uh uh get up or something get up get
down morning
cold pizza stop yourself don't touch me
one of these
i think it was don't touch me how would
brockmire have called the final seconds
of the jets beating the rams yesterday
well i think they just would have been
one long whale and moan like a banshee
whale but
i've been working on this so i emailed
this to fritz i want brock meyer to he i
want to
you know brock meyer is famous for
saying that the mets are the yankees
of not being the yankees okay i want to
expand on this
that the jets are the lebron james
of being worse than the knicks and the
knicks
are the patrick mahomes of being the
knicks
of being themselves a lot of math i'm
giving you a lot of math
i know word problems here this i didn't
think brockmire was that deep
yeah i've given this all a lot of
thought only after he's been drinking is
he
is he that deep yeah uh well keep your
head up though
this is just perfect can i tell you how
every year goes for me can i share with
you as a jets mets knicks fan
so this is so we're in december we're
almost at the end of the year
by now i have definitely given up on the
jets
usually that's by thanksgiving at the
outside yeah
this year was weird because we had this
weird trevor lawrence hope now that's
destroyed
pretty much for almost for sure so then
around this time of year you turn to the
next go well let's see what the knicks
can do
right we'll see what happens by i'd
say february that's not you know that's
not going to really happen
with the knicks anymore so you're off
the knicks but you got spring training
so you look forward
to well let's see what the mets got
going on this year that dream usually is
done
by the all-star break by july maybe
august
just about in time to say well let's see
what the jets have going on this year
you're on this loop it's just you'll
never get out of that loop
i was wondering though could the
simpsons do an episode of the jets did
they
how much how much sports
do the simpsons do well every once in a
while
one of the fame the most famous classic
episodes is that homer at the bad
episode which is actually
featured in like the baseball hall of
fame right now where we had
all these baseball players a great
episode um
every once in a while they touch on
sports but actually i should i'm going
to ask
for like a jets met's knicks
who does homer root for i mean he's in
the midwest he's probably a chiefs fan
wouldn't he be
well the local uh the local um
uh minor league team is the springfield
isotopes
and that's who homer's fan of which i
think they actually did name
i think there's actually a real team in
the isotopes they're um in
texas i think yeah i think yeah the
isotopes i thought that's such a great
nickname like there's nobody
who's known as the isotopes other than
the isotopes
but if you had homer somehow screw up
the jets went you know like this would
have been perfect
like homer somehow would have cost the
jets yesterday
against the rams and they don't get
trevor lawrence and you i mean you could
have trevor lawrence would look great in
a cartoon
with the flowing hair there i don't mean
to tell the geniuses at simpsons
how to do their job but you know but
you're noodling this so maybe matt
would be interested in at least you guys
i mean come on after all these years you
gotta
you're running out of time so long it'll
be therapeutic for me yeah and we god
knows we've done an episode but
everything else
well i got to circle back to makai
becton for a second that was absurd and
terrible
what he said i mean of course we
understand
no one expects the players to tank
nobody expects mckay bechten
or or anybody not not or sam donald not
to try
you know they almost so no one would
ever fault them
or to be happy that they won a game but
you gotta at least tip your hat to the i
guess he's too young to understand yeah
but he's gotta have sam darnold's back
like literally he has his back that he i
mean sam darnold wins he can keep his
job
hank you but
you can't say to jet fans you're not a
true
fan if you were rooting for the jets to
lose you can say
i understand how jets fans could feel
that way but you gotta understand we're
trying to win every game we can
we gotta look our jobs and our lives on
the line here
no one would fault him for that but
you're not a true fan
come on now
i don't think you'd say it to makai
bechten's face though i absolutely i
would
through a zoom you'd be
that's a big man that you'd be saying
i think what you said is really stupid
all right you know
i didn't say it was stupid i know but
that was that was the feeling
i got does this conversation make you
feel bad
it was this cathartic in any way for you
oh yeah i mean i feel very privileged
that i get to uh
oh you know speak to the likes of you
like whine to the likes of you about
what my jets met snicks uh sadness
does your wife understand this pain god
she didn't she's a philly
philadelphia fan so my house is horrible
for me
she's used to heartache too yeah but you
know
my father-in-law who's a lovely guy
he literally he says goodbye to me on
the phone
this guy says goodbye he goes all right
i love you mets suck
this is goodbye well with that all
uh i'll say goodbye to you hank and uh
and happy holidays
and uh mets suck
thank you hank it's great to talk to you
you too dad happy holidays to everybody
thank you buddy that's hank cazario of
course was brock meyer
and uh the great voices on the simpsons